in the wake of the worst rioting in
living memory the politicians were
talking tough social media stood accused
of allowing the organization there's
some of the violence the prime minister
spoke of restricting access to sites
some senior police even contemplated
that temporary closure just over a
fortnight later all such talk has
disappeared the government has confirmed
they'll be seeking no additional powers
to control social media we have lot as a
government said we're going to do this
all we've said is we're going to look at
whether it might be right to do this
we're not going to in order to become
like Iran or China we're not gonna start
suddenly cutting people off in reality
it would have been next to impossible to
control networks which in many cases
aren't even based in the UK and the
government it now seems doesn't want to
be compared to the kind of repressive
regimes who regularly close down their
media outlets especially as curing the
Arab Spring for prime minister was one
of the first to applaud the use of
social media in those countries it
belongs to a new generation for whom
technology the internet social media is
a powerful tool in the hands of the
citizens not a means of their oppression
I can only assume David Cameron had a
rush of blood to the head if you start
to ban platforms people soon find other
ways of communicating it's also I think
just in terms of freedom of expression
is exactly the wrong signal we want to
show to the world although a handful of
people have been charged or convicted of
orchestrating trouble via social media
many doubted had a significant role in
the riots The Guardian special projects
editor one of a number of journalists
who've examined the influence these
sites had during the Troubles their
conclusion the positives far outweigh
the negatives the Twitter activity
didn't come before the disorder in
particular towns and cities now in large
part it came after the disorder so it's
people communicating with each other
talking to each other trying to help
each other out and two hundred thousand
of those tweets about eight percent of
the whole data set
were related to the riot cleanup so the
post riot social media summit ended with
an emphasis on improving relations and
cooperation with the police the bosses
of Twitter Facebook and blackberry
messenger will determine to fight their
corner and despite the area of posturing
it's clear the politicians now realized
post restrictions simply aren't workable
mark white sky use